So there are many things to criticize from
yesterday's Robert Mueller testimony before
two different houses committees.
But if we zoom out and we're honest with ourselves,
the big picture is that Robert Mueller's testimony
confirmed that Donald Trump is impeachable
based on what Donald Trump has done as per
the Mueller report, if Democrats want to pursue
it.
And that's a question that I brought up yesterday
with you, which Democrats need to very, very
soon decide.
Yesterday I made many of the criticisms that
could be made of the Mueller testimony.
Mueller was very restrained at times.
He seemed confused.
He often wasn't able to hear the questions
misstated even whether his own report took
a position on some things he was asked about
and then was reminded after saying he has
not taken a position on that.
Well, you took a position on it in the report.
At one point he said, can you remind me who
Corey Lewandowski was when he was asked about
Lewandowski?
And if you were expecting fireworks of the
explosive kind, then you certainly didn't
get it.
But Robert Mueller did quietly confirm truly
reprehensible behavior by Donald Trump, which
the right has been adamant about refusing
to admit even took place.
And the major revelations during the hearing
were mostly just the moments where Robert
Mueller in very short answers, often with
yes or that's true, uh, confirmed the dishonesty
and the obstructive nature of Donald Trump's
behavior and actions.
There isn't even any anything to play for
you.
From the Republican questioning of Mueller,
their goal was to discredit Robert Mueller.
They treated him like garbage.
Remember Muller didn't choose to start this
probe.
He was appointed to run it.
He was brought in to do it.
The idea that he was part of the problem or
part of some conspiracy to take down Trump
is laughable.
And Republicans wouldn't be trying to assail
Mueller's character and the process of the
investigation itself if they didn't believe
that the content of the report was damaging
to Trump.
And it is.
So let's get to some of the moments where
under questioning from Democrats in the House
of Representatives on these two committees,
Robert Mueller confirmed that yes, there is
impeachable action by Donald Trump.
Here he was questioned by congresswoman val
Demings.
Molders said that Trump's written answers
to his questions.
Number one, we're under oath, and number two,
we're not answered truthfully.
This is obstructive.
This is lying under oath.
Mueller told the congresswoman that Trump's
answers were quote, generally untruthful.
This is a massive indictment on Donald Trump's
behavior.
He lied under oath to a federal investigators.
Mueller exposed that due to limited scope
of, of the investigation.
There are huge areas about which we still
know very, very little and investigations
are actually continuing.
That is something Republicans have said.
The opposite of Republicans have said the
scope was too wide.
Mueller confirmed yesterday the scope, if
anything, was actually too narrow.
Molar confirmed that White House counsel,
Don McGahn, was pressured to lie by the White
House about whether he was ever asked by Donald
Trump to fire the former special counsel,
Robert Mueller.
This is an impeachable offense in and of itself.
If Democrats wanted to take it up, quote from
Democrat Karen Bass, the president told the
White House Staff Secretary Rob Porter to
try to pressure Don McGahn to make a false
denial.
Is that correct?
To which Robert Mueller said, that's correct.
That's a big deal.
It's easy to get lost in the scandal numbness
and in Robert Mueller, you know, seeming a
little shaky up there, but this is huge that
this is obstruction of justice period.
Mueller confirmed that a president can be
indicted after leaving office
DOJ Under Department of Justice Policy.
The president could be prosecuted for obstruction
of justice crimes after he leaves offices.
Correct.
Thank you.
Now we knew that molar implied it in his report
and in the hearing, Mueller made it abundantly
clear that that's the case and this came up
against a, this came up again rather with
Congressman Ken Buck, which is interesting
because had Ken buck known that Robert Mueller
was going to answer in this way, my guess
is he wouldn't even have gone down this path.
Take a look.
The, uh, could you charge the president with
a trial after he left office?
Yes.
You believe that he committed, you could charge
the president nine states with obstruction
of justice after he left office?
Yes, ethically under the ethical standards.
Well, I, I, I'm not certain because I haven't
looked at the ethical standards, but the LLC
[inaudible] opinion says that the prosecutor
y can not bring a charge against the sitting
president.
Nonetheless, he can continue the investigation
to see if there are any, uh, other, a person
to might be drawn into the conspiracy.
Another point, which of course anyone who
read the report already knew, but many of
yours may not have.
Mueller did not clear Trump of obstruction
of justice.
If you've been following this, you're reacting
to me saying, yeah, David, we know that a
lot of people didn't know this
director mother, the president has repeatedly
claimed that your report found there was no
obstruction and that had completely and totally
exonerated him.
But that is not what your report said.
Is it correct?
That is not what the report said.
And now reading from page two of volume two
of your report that's on the screen, you wrote
quote, if we had confidence after a thorough
investigation of the facts that the president
clearly did not commit obstruction of justice,
we would so state based on the facts and the
applicable legal standards, however, we are
unable to reach that judgment close quote.
Now does that say there was no obstruction?
No.
In fact, you were actually unable to conclude
the president did not commit obstruction of
justice.
Is that correct?
Well, we, uh, uh, at the outset determined
that we, uh, when it came to the, uh, the,
the president's culpability, uh, we needed
to, uh, we mean it, we needed to go forward
only after taking into account the OLC opinion
that indicated that a president sitting president
cannot be, uh, indicted.
So the report did not conclude that he did
not commit obstruction of justice.
Is that correct?
That is correct.
And what about total exoneration?
Did you actually totally exonerate the president?
No.
Now in fact, your reports expressly stated
it does not exonerate the president.
It does.
And your investigation actually found quote
multiple acts by the president that were capable
of exerting undue influence over law enforcement
investigations, including the Russian interference
and obstruction investigations.
Is that correct?
Correct.
Another key moment if you try to commit obstruction
and fail, that is still a crime, right?
Yes, it is.
Congresswoman Debbie mcardle Powell asking
about that.
Uh, I want to refer you now to volume two.
Page one 58 you wrote that quote, the president's
efforts to influence the investigation were
mostly unsuccessful, but that is largely because
the persons who surrounded the president declined
to carry out orders or exceed to his request.
Is that right?
That is accurate.
And that is what we found.
And you're basically referring to senior advisors
who disobeyed the president's orders like
White House counsel, Don McGahn, former Trump
campaign manager, Corey Lewandowski.
Is that right?
Well, we have not specified that person's
bedroom.
Well in, in page one 58 White House counsel,
Don McGahn quote, did not tell the acting
attorney general that the special counsel
must be removed, but was instead prepared
to resign over the president's orders.
You also explained that an attempt to obstruct
justice does not have to succeed to be a crime,
right?
True.
Simply attempting to obstruct justice can
be a crime, correct?
Yes.
If I am Trump, if I am a Republican, if I'm
in Donald Trump's inner circle, I am decidedly
relieved after these hearings, despite the
fact that the content of the hearings was
extraordinarily damaging from Robert Mueller,
it wasn't presented in a particularly dynamic
way and the next question for Democrats is
going to be, what do we do?
I said it yesterday, Democrats need to decide,
uh, is an impeachment inquiry going to start
right now?
Is an impeachment inquiry going to start but
in six months timed to be more damaging to
Donald Trump or are they moving on and they're
going to focus on 2020 whatever the answer
is, I've said what I think should happen.
I think there is more than enough evidence
here for an impeachment inquiry and I think
it should start whenever it is.
Democrats believe it should start.
If they're not going to do it, then it's time
to move on.
The next question is, and this is going to
be fun, how did Donald Trump react to all
of this?
The answer is like a completely unhinged,
disconnected, petulant child.